[Musique]
sur les deux départements il y a il y a
40 personnes qui vont être d'astreinte
24 heures sur 24 à compter de cet
épisode et jusqu'à la moitié du mois de
mars et dès ce soir nos 32 saleuses
partiront préventivement traités les
points les plus importants du réseau
parce que l'épisode de neige annoncé on
parle de 1 à 5 cm le verglas par contre
on va être dans un environnement
température entre -2 et 2 degrés qui est
complètement propice à l'apparition de
verglas et là c'est extrêmement
difficile d'intervenir une fois que le
verglet posé puisque le sel glisse sur
le sur la couche de glace
pour l'instant l'heure de priorité il
est plutôt par la classification et
l'importance de nos axes on a on a trois
catégories et on a 340 km du réseau
inter départemental qui est dit deux
catégories une c'est à dire les voix les
plus capacitaires les deux fois de voix
enfin tout les tous les axes qui
accueillent le plus de trafic sur
évidemment ces axes là qui sont traités
en priorité
ça fait très longtemps qu'il y a pas eu
un épisode avec avec du verglas donc là
on est dans un environnement dans une
configuration météo avec un sol très
froid avec peu de neige annoncé mais
peut-être de la pluie et donc la pluie
sur un seul très fort vous le savez ça
fait du verglas et comme il n'est pas
annoncé de température au dessus de 0
avant ce weekend on est dans une
confédération à risque sur la partie
verglass ça fait très longtemps pour le
coup que on n'a pas connu ça
[Musique]